[Music]
one of these three men is an expert on
unidentified flying objects what is your
name please
my name is Jay Allen Hyatt
my name is Jay Allen heinek
my name is Jay Allen heineck
jail and heineck came into the UFO field
with the typical scientific attitude
which is they shouldn't be studied
there's nothing to them
ultimately that changed and that's sort
of the core of the J Ellen heineck story
i j Allen heineck I'm a consultant to
the United States Air Force on
unidentified flying object like so many
other key figures of that era heinek had
to push against the government that he
once worked for and stand up for the
truth I am also professor of astronomy
and director of a large University
Observatory
believed that science was the tool
science could get us to an understanding
of what UFOs are and that's what he
advocated for
there are a lot of people who don't
always understand his rationale for the
things he did or the things he said but
heinek's impact today I think is
immeasurable only one of these men is
the real J Allen heineck the other two
are imposters and we'll try to fool this
panel on to tell the truth
[Music]
get reports every night
around it I'd like to report a usual
[Music]
the US government closed its formal
study of UFOs Project Blue Book in late
1969.
and the government as a whole says we're
not interested in the off all reports
the air force made the decision let's
get out of this business of
investigating UFOs
our business is National Security we've
seen no threat let's stop Project Blue
Book
JL and heineck who was the scientist who
worked for Project Blue Book for almost
20 years actually came through that with
the opposite perspective which was that
UFOs were something serious and they
should be investigated
in my association with Project Blue Book
I don't I know very well that it was not
a scientific project
I also know that they never never would
notify the media when an interesting
case came up they did everything they
could
to keep it down so they definitely
withheld information
Dr heineck realized that this was a
serious problem the UFO reports could
not all be explained and that the
military should be taking this more
seriously we now know that there were
UFO cases during this time period that
did seem to have National Security
implications I know that when I was a
part of Blue Book there were a number of
cases that never got into blue book
They're Witnesses this was preserved at
a missile base this was observed by an
Air Force pilot you mean to tell me that
the CIA or the FBI in the government
hasn't investigated this I think the
public would be shocked to realize that
there were incidents going back even
into the 60s where our nuclear missile
silos were being interfered with
production facilities weapons facilities
we've had incidents over numerous ICBM
bases
during the Cold War intercontinental
ballistic missiles called icbms were
strategically located throughout
Northern parts of the United States
where they were within Striking Distance
of the Soviet Union
there were almost identical UFO events
at two of the Minutemen ICBM locations
at Minot Air Force Base in North Dakota
in 1966 and at Malmstrom Air Force Base
in Montana in 1967.
my name is Robert Salas in 1967 I was a
lieutenant in the Air Force
stationed in miles from Air Force Base
Montana
my name is David shimley I'm a retired
Air Force captain
at Minot Air Force Base North Dakota
in 1966 my responsibility was to launch
our 10 nuclear tip missiles upon
appropriate and verified order
my name is Robert Jamison
I was a first lieutenant the United
States Air Force Malmstrom Air Force
Base in Montana one of my jobs was to if
a missile goes off alert for any reason
is to go out and restart it
the Air Force includes missile men here
at Malmstrom Air Force Base a strategic
missile Wing controls the most modern
minute man in its underground silo
the Air Force Specialists on this job
buy continuous Readiness to launch their
bird help prevent rather than start a
nuclear war
we had Minuteman 1 missiles and that's
what 800 kiloton weapon and just for
reference the weapons that were dropped
on Hiroshima Nagasaki were 20 kilotons
that capability is helping to keep the
peace we have a policy of mutually
assured destruction it would be suicide
for us or our potential adversaries to
launch a nuclear attack unless they
could disable that capability in that
system
then they could conceivably
decapitate the United States destroy the
capital without fear of retaliatory
response and change the global balance
of power
our location was 60 feet underground
we are very well protected it was a
concrete steel reinforced capsule and
this capsule was sitting below what we
call the launch controls facility
we had six security guards topside they
had the responsibility for making sure
there was nobody trying to break in
fact traveled to base to attend the
pre-departure crew briefing
after the briefing several missile Crews
came up to me and said did you hear what
happened overnight
[Music]
sometime in the evening hours I'd get up
a call from the main guard upstairs he
tells me that there are strange lights
flying over the facility
they're looking at reddish orange
glowing pulsating light
it's hovering just above the front gate
and he pointed with his arms and he says
it was right out there hovering and
motionless and without sound
they did think that there was a solid
object within the light sort of oval
shaped I kind of dismissed it I even
said you mean like UFOs and uh kind of
laughed and even he said well they're
not airplanes sir
about five minutes later he calls back
and he's screaming into the phone is
very frightened he's babbling he said
he's got all the guards out there with
their weapons drawn they wanted orders
on what to do
I told him make sure nothing enters the
fenced area
when I hung up the phone I thought we
were under attack by who or what I had
no idea
and that'll be good bells and whistles
going off at our control panel and we
could see the lights going from green to
Red all across the board meaning the
missiles were inoperable now
if the president had given the order to
launch the missiles we could not have
launched them
[Music]
losing 10 missiles was a shock
except for that instance I never lost
more than one missile at a time
somehow someway Vehicles were able to
maneuver right over those icbms and turn
them off
we don't know why they went down they're
still doing well
there's no other reason I can think of
that would cause the tend to go off
alert within seconds
we knew it it wasn't an ordinary
man-made machine because we had nothing
like that
after the incident I was required not to
speak to anybody about it I attempted to
question the security guard and he said
sorry sir I've been told to keep quiet
and he was told that as far as you're
concerned it never happened
I had to go through a spatial briefing
this is where they told me
you're not supposed to say ever again
that something happened feels nothing
happened
of course the first thing I did when I
got home is hey guess what happened
there was a man from Air Force office of
special investigations all he wanted me
to do was to sign this document stating
I would never speak about this again
[Music]
once we signed that document We Were
released told to leave and that was that
I never spoke about any of this until
1994 so I was about 27 years later
three years after the Maelstrom incident
in which 10 missiles were shut down the
Air Force released a fact sheet to the
public announcing the close of Project
Blue Book and it stated that no UFO
reported
investigated or evaluated by the Air
Force was ever an indication of a threat
to our national security
meaning not even one has represented any
kind of national security threat
that was certainly a
a lie let's let's use the right word
the Air Force knew full well these were
UFO related incidents that UFOs were
responsible for the shutdown of these
missiles
found out later in
that in fact a secret memo had
circulated called the bollander memo
which stated that any national security
cases could continue to be reported
through channels already in place
and so it was a complete black and white
contradiction between what was being
said to the public
and what was being said behind the
scenes
[Music]
there's something's in our atmosphere
that we just don't know what it is
these things seem to be interested in
our nuclear capabilities
and that's something that we should be
concerned about
I kept a secret for 40 years it was a
long time to have this burden on the
back of my shoulders I'm normally quiet
personality and I just don't want to be
in the Limelight
but the public needs to know this
Robert Salas did not speak out about
what happened for many many years and it
shows how intimidated these people are
to come forward
decades will go by and they won't even
talk about it
good morning my name is David sindley
in 2001
I found an article describing Robert
salas's incident
and when I saw it I said oh my God the
incident that he had was almost
identical to the one I had
I experienced a just a joyful freedom
and I finally was able to tell my wife
my secret
and
so
thanks Robert for helping me out
after the guards had called me and
literally begged me to come out and see
them because this was very
traumatic experience for the guards but
I just signed a non-disclosure statement
so I had to tell them on the phone that
I could not see them so when I talk
about this I do it partly for those
Airmen that begged me to come see him
and I just couldn't do it
there's a shyness and a reluctance on
the part of many witnesses and
understandably so against reporting
because too many have been ridiculed and
the life has been made somewhat
miserable for them
Dr heinek grew increasingly
disillusioned by the Air Force's
dismissive approach to these sightings
and dismissive approach to the evidence
heineck gradually realized that this was
a subject that demanded a serious study
back when heinek was in Project Blue
Book there was a case it involved a
father and his two sons in Idaho one day
they all saw this object just zoomed
down this Gully down the riverbed and
disappear they all three saw it heineck
found it fairly convincing he ended up
writing it off as as something with a
natural cause
but that was heinic's official report to
Project Blue Book
why this is significant is years later
when heinek started to change his mind
he had regrets about that specific case
he said with that case I should have
said you know what it doesn't add up
completely I think there's more going on
here I'm not going to dismiss it I'm
going to try to find out more so that
was kind of the first in heinek's
facade as a debunker
I began to get threatened out because it
was the people themselves I said to
myself no come on how much longer am I
going to call these people crazy
and when I changed my glasses you might
say a little bit and took a view that
maybe these people aren't crazy
and began to realize what the sort of
people they were good solid people I
said to myself well
the time has come
to maybe change my attitude
[Music]
with the United States Air Force leaving
the role behind of taking in UFO
investigations this left a large vacuum
that civilian organizations began to
fill in 1974 Jay Allen heineck founded
the center for UFO studies abbreviated
kufos this was a civilian group composed
of very qualified people that runs the
gamut of the average person with an
enthusiasm to a very highly trained
scientist or academic and the records
that they provided are absolutely
crucial
[Music]
yeah
I'm Mark rodiger of the scientific
director of the center for UFO studies
in Chicago
Dr haddock mentored me and designated me
as a successor
Dr heineck was the classic Professor he
loved teaching he also really enjoyed
jokes you know a good time he wasn't
stuffy he had a little twinkle in his
eye people really warmed up to him
Alan was very open-minded and that is
really the background of him being
interested in UFOs
UFO groups you know they're not massive
organizations in fact we're now sitting
in the basement in my UFO office here in
my house
you know the center is really like a
scientific Think Tank
Dr heineck realized that there was a
need for a focused professional group to
study UFOs that involves mainly three
things being a place for people to
report sightings number two is to be a
place for Reliable information we
publish a journal periodical with
monographs
and finally of course a place to do
research we've stayed pretty close to
that mission all through the years
one of the first things that kufos did
was establish a national hotline for UFO
Reporting
they distributed this hotline to law
enforcement agencies around the country
and said put this on your bulletin board
if you ever get a call from someone who
has seen a UFO call us on this hotline
when we will do the investigation okay
but it didn't look like
anything I know of
but there was a big difference between
civilian and Military investigations of
UFOs
the military has access to other
information civilian Stone
I went to see Don Robson at the White
House well mainly because it's a friend
of mine and said to him look they have
this Center for UFO studies and I wanted
you to know that should this subject
ever get to the presidential the
Congressional level but there is a group
of scientists who are ready to work on
it and I said I do have a certain
responsibility to these scientists are
we spinning our Wheels if this work has
already been done by somebody else I
said because of my responsibility to be
scientists I felt that I had a need to
know
and he snapped right back at me says you
do not have a need to know
you interpret that any darn way you want
in any case you cannot stop scientists
from working and that's the whole point
of being a scientist they're
individualists they're going to do what
they damn please anyway
in the 70s and 80s in general government
officials were not talking about UFOs
but some presidents were also interested
in getting information about UFOs when
Jimmy Carter was the governor of Georgia
in 1969 he had a sighting with a group
of other Witnesses
saw a very bright light in the Western
sky and it got closer and closer and
then it seemed to stop in its proximity
to us and then the color of a change
from white to Blue to red
Jimmy Carter was very impressed by that
it really impacted him then in 1973 he
filed a written report on this with a
number of Civilian UFO groups so it's on
the record
so when he did become president he would
approached NASA to see if they would
open up a new investigation that could
continue what the Air Force had been
doing prior to closing down Project Blue
Book the Air Force would not have wanted
this to happen seven years after closing
Project Blue Book so the Air Force
jumped in on the process and said to
NASA we don't want you to do this
after a series of exchanges
NASA did decline the president's request
Under Pressure to answer by the end of
the year Essa concluded that it would be
pointless to mount a new research effort
because of the lack of physical evidence
it was kind of stunning that a request
from the president would have been
denied
thank you
if there is no concrete evidence of
people from outer space how do you write
a whole book about UFOs well that's
exactly why I called it the UFO
experience instead of something that
would have sold more like sex in the UFO
I called it the UFO experience because
that's what I was talking about the
experience that people had and you can't
convince a person who's had a real UFO
experience that he hasn't had it in the
early 70s Jay Allen heineck came out
with his Monumental book called the UFO
experience it wasn't just about research
he was somebody that would listen and
took people seriously who had had
sightings and had experiences
he would go on lots of TV shows and
radio interviews and he was a public
figure advocating for official
recognition and study of UFOs
over the Space Program taking off there
was a Groundswell of interest in outer
space
[Applause]
it was a national movement and so
people's imaginations of course run wild
Hollywood was able to capture that and
feed people's thirst and Imagination and
it led to a long-standing powerful genre
made a force be with you
so UFOs became a cultural creative
imaginative area and heinek's book was a
big hit Dr J Alan heineck Stephen
Spielberg bought the rights to heinek's
book
and hired Dr heineck as a technical
consultant and so Spielberg worked with
heineck in helping to get the facts
accurate for his movie Close Encounters
yeah I was very influenced by Jay Alan
heineck because he was not looking at
UFOs as science fiction but he was
looking at them as science
speculation so I met with him and I used
him and I picked his brain and and he
consulted with me Dr heineck was the
fellow that coined the term Close
Encounters across the counter the first
kind is one is close but nothing really
happened
close encounter the second kind includes
physical damage to the environment that
could be landing pad imprints in the
grass where a UFO was said to have
landed and the Close Encounters of the
Third Kind are the most interesting of
all Close Encounter of the Third Kind
is really when you meet him
it was clear that Spielberg wanted real
science real data accurate information
about UFOs and that's why he called on J
Allen heineck
they were drawing from real U.S
government information
on how these things operated and
maneuvered
Hypersonic velocities or fast speed
instantaneous acceleration even
biological effects where Richard dreyf
is half his face has his sunburn those
were all observables that we were seeing
in the U.S government real observables
that made their way onto the Hollywood
screen and that's because Steven
Spielberg was provided information from
people from Project Blue Book
along with heineck Spielberg also talked
to Jacques valet a French scientist who
was well known in the UFO field and had
written numerous books on the topic I
had the privilege of working with Dr
heineck for five years
we built the first computer-based data
catalog of UFO sightings starting with
the Air Force flies
which covered about 20 000 cases
software
didn't come from all over their country
the French scientists in the movie
character of Lacombe was based Loosely
on on me
France has an official scientific
committee for UFOs that includes
physicists the military including
sociologists and psychologists
by letting the project team leader be a
Frenchman it immediately gave more of a
depth to the understanding of UFOs
in the whole history of American movies
it's always they come from somewhere
they kill somebody so we bring the tanks
and they destroy all the tanks
that's a very American way of looking at
an alien life form if everything's ready
here on the Dark Side of the Moon
play the five tones the movie was the
first movie in which we were greeting
these aliens and they were coming to us
as as equal and we were going to have an
intelligent discussion with them our
intelligent Exchange
[Music]
close encounters with just captured the
spirit of the mystery of the phenomenon
the scariness of the phenomenon and kind
of the impact that it has on people
whatever the government may think about
them unidentified flying objects seem to
be popular with the people Columbia
Pictures reports that its film Close
Encounters of a Third Kind has grossed
39 million dollars in three weeks
I owe a lot to Jay Allen heinek his
instilling in me a professional's point
of view on this kind of field reporting
and he helped me make the movie more
credible than it would have been without
his his existence Steven Spielberg
actually brought him on set for when
they filmed the movies huge climax at
the secret UFO base in Wyoming United
States Navy 443-431
and of course Close Encounters became a
household term because of Steven
Spielberg's movie and really catapulted
heinic too the degree of celebrity
therefore the real Dr J Allen heineck
please
stand up
even though heinek worked for our
government for almost two decades what
he was doing in the 70s and 80s seemed
to have no impact at all on the
government and sightings continued
there's the Fantastic sightings last
year and this year in the Westchester
and Putnam County areas those are
literally out of this world I can find
no logical explanation for them
[Music]
we were coming home from grad school
and we were just yacking like we are now
and all of a sudden Doris says what are
those lights up there
was driving north on 118 and as his
coaching the light here I looked into
the northern Skies sort of what appeared
to be a large aircraft with Landon
lights
flying very low about 500c
and it stopped and it rotated 180
degrees and started to head West
I looked up at Interstate 84 and it was
a parking lot
people were out of their cars blinking
rides pointing up at the sky and there
was that City of Lights hovering over in
my backyard
and it went like from night to to broad
daylight
and all of a sudden it was it's going to
land it's going to land
when I came to the station the phones
were ringing off the hook
the object came directly over my head
less than 500 feet above me
Kevin host guy
it's totally quiet no sound whatsoever
you could hear a pin drop
and I said oh what do I do with my
family
how am I going to handle all this
what I saw was
unbelievable mindbox
the whole town saw what I saw
beginning in around 1983 there was an
incredibly dramatic series of sightings
that took place in the Hudson Valley
area of New York State and in
Connecticut which was actually a wave
because it took place over years people
would report these UFOs to the police or
maybe to local UFO groups and a lot of
people were kind of odd and frightened
it was a little spooky how come
explainable what Jim Brooks saw there
was a lot of local reporting some local
civilian investigation our researchers
have set up a special UFO Hotline in
Westchester it was something that
involved hundreds at least Witnesses if
not more
from our government even though these
gigantic craft were cruising around over
a part of the United States
the Federal Aviation Administration has
joined the Air Force and many
astronomers in attributing most UFO
sightings to man-made objects and
natural phenomenon believe it or not the
planet Venus
is a fairly common UFO sighting it moved
very slowly we looked up in the sky we
saw six lights in a v-shape even after
all these Witnesses had seen these
objects and had reported them to their
local police it still became a kind of a
joke the head of my school he said you
know some people might think you're
crazy
I was the commissioner of Motor Vehicles
and I was involved in a political race
at that time the last thing I wanted to
be known for was little green people or
UFOs my husband also thought I was nuts
and so I didn't talk about it too much
what is interesting tragic and amusing
all of them one of the same time is that
lots of people are afraid to talk about
it they their friends will laugh at them
and so forth and uh
we need to let those people
feel safe and talk about it
on August 25th of 1984 heineck came to
the Hudson Valley and he gave a talk at
the middle school there
this was the last case that he was
involved with before he died and it made
a huge impression on him here is a
sketch of the thing going on in
Westchester County now this is large
Boomerang shaped object that moves
slowly far below the stall speed of
aircraft moves silently I've been told
by highly responsible witnesses that it
is as large as the football field
it speaks to the importance of the
Hudson Valley wave that Jay Alan heineck
came here he thought it was important
enough
to speak to the witnesses to go to the
sites
I spend a weekend with Dr heinek
Dr highly could ask you a question and
he sit back and he would listen and if
one of my kids jumped into the
conversation he would just kindly just
put up his hand and go I'll get right
back to you a little wink and you were
the most important person for that
moment he was talking to you that's the
way he made me feel
it was very important for these
Witnesses who were not getting any
official recognition that somebody like
Jay Allen heineck an astronomer who had
worked for the government that he came
there and spoke with them and took them
seriously
and we walk through the whole sighting
he wanted to go every place and every
time we made a stop he said what were
you feeling do you feel anything in your
gut did you feel connected to this
object
it made a huge difference to have him on
site during the wave
in the Westchester case in New Yorkers
we had Witnesses geographically
independent of each other didn't know
each other and yet reported identically
the same things now you cannot call that
mass hallucination
lack of scientific involvement or
government acknowledgment of
those encourages people's imaginations
to go wild with what are they hiding we
called the police when we got home and
they didn't tell us that night but a
couple of days later we were reading
they thought they were ultralights the
planes the chief meteorologist at the
Westchester County Airport to some 25
years experience told me that when he
saw it it moved very slowly like a ship
docking at a birth now that cannot
possibly be ultra lights flying in
formation that's just out of the
question information is one of the art
one of the reasons cited including an
article in in discover magazine this
article that was in discover magazine
talks about the pilots who were going up
in hoaxing UFOs and it implies that
that's probably what all the sightings
were
the engines
planes fly all the time you hear 7 000
people coming out and saying ah I saw
planes over my head no they saw
something different
ultralights they make noise
so uh
we've never had a good explanation
so these Pilots did a huge disservice by
creating this hoax situation to confuse
everything and to bring a lack of
credibility and to give the government
something to hang their hat on when they
were asked what people were actually
seeing
people began doubting themselves
it kept the entire wave suppressed
heinek who's just stunned by the fact
that this was not getting attention the
subject came up in the United Nations
recently we have reports from 133
different countries and the same pattern
exists around the world it's not just
localized in one particular country you
see
so while our government was telling the
public that there was nothing to UFOs
that the investigations had all been
shut down
documents reveal that officials were in
fact monitoring cases in other countries
they were saying
we're saying very similar to what was
seen in the Hudson Valley
[Music]
this map was prepared by Dr Jacques
Valley
UFO reports are truly Global and they
seem to occur in waves or flaps as they
are often called
notice how the slabs have been
distributed throughout the years and
over the world
this is truly an international
phenomenon there's no question about it
there's a very similar pattern very
similar reports foreign militaries are
also having encounters the Belgian Air
Force had some extraordinary encounters
foreign
a few years after the Hudson Valley wave
a very similar wave occurred in Belgium
these large black triangles again all
the characteristic silent low beams of
light hovering
the Belgian authorities would scramble
jets in order to try to get a better
look at the objects they wanted to
identify what it was that was invading
protected airspace over their country it
felt that this was their responsibility
the f-16s that the Belgian military had
attract these objects on radar so they
they actually have radar imagery of the
unknown moving through Belgian airspace
and the contrast from how the Belgian
government handled it there versus how
our government didn't handle the events
in Hudson Valley are really striking
Belgian Air Force became actively
involved with a group of scientists to
collect reports from Witnesses they
assigned a kernel to head up an
investigation
and they held a press conference
packed with media in which they
disclosed everything they knew and and
how they were approaching this
and the public were encouraged to file
reports
Air Force officers were coming forward
and speaking about it
they gave it a legitimacy that we have
yet to see here in this country
you said the government stopped
investigating back in 1969 do these UFO
Watchers have any reason to expect the
government to get re-involved in
investigating these claims right now
they're a bit disappointed the
government has not gotten more involved
than it has in the last 10 years but we
do know that the CIA and the defense
department has been doing some research
into other sightings in other nations
like the Soviet Union and Iran but in
the United States they seem very
skeptical
the Belgian case was documented by U.S
government officials Colonel de Brauer
had approached American officials to
inquire whether this was ours and we had
told them no and we had said also we'd
like to know whose it was
so there was a document filed about the
Belgian wave but no document filed about
a wave in our own country at least that
we are aware of
to me the greatest evidence for the
existence of something strange going on
is the caliber of many of the witnesses
for instance in Westchester we had
meteorologists a Navy test pilot IBM
Executives a priest are they all saying
the same thing that it is not
explainable to them by any conventional
explanation you just said a charter
that's exactly what they're saying
they're seeing the same things you know
there were so many people that saw it it
wasn't enough
probably wouldn't
have time I might have told my family
right yeah but there were so many people
that saw it that I was fine with you
know yeah spreading the word me too and
everybody that I told said they were
sorry they didn't see it
a lot of people took solace in the fact
that heineck was a guy who was on their
side
if you witnessed the UFO heinek was one
person who would take you seriously
wouldn't make fun of you and really try
to get a full picture of your experience
and that that's so huge just to someone
who has seen something weird in the sky
and doesn't know how to tell anyone
about it
I felt validated that's the way Dr
heineck made me feel so I could say
there's nothing wrong with me and
nothing wrong with my eyes and nothing
wrong with my intuition they're all
intact
Dr heineck was someone who was very
alive very open he told me once that the
reason he became interested in UFOs was
about the challenges about you know what
is this world if this is real what does
that mean for human existence
the last thing heinek did before leaving
this Earth was try to understand the
nature of the denial and the disconnect
among human beings when something this
dramatic happens
heinek wrote an essay it was a rough
draft that was left on his computer when
he died he said how is it possible that
in the United States where even trivial
events are often flashed across the
world
only one National TV and radio network
carried an account of these utterly
astounding sightings
was no one minding the store was
everyone asleep at the switch
heinek was a different person than he
was previously when he worked at Project
Blue Book here he was saying UFOs there
are scientific interests
the witnesses should be taken seriously
it was just the most profoundly
important moment and setting a course of
events that continued through the 70s
80s and 90s
starting as a complete skeptic I
underwent a transformation
and now I guess the best way of saying
it is it's an itch that I just have to
scratch
I feel that we have a phenomenon that
could be of tremendous potential
importance to the human race and I feel
that strongly about it
[Music]
or something like that it's usually
right over me
highly restricted airspace you don't
want something up there that doesn't
belong there
culture as a whole didn't really take
UFO seriously I stuck with it despite
the level of ridicule for decades
there's a huge
huge responses I want to break the story
[Music]
thank you